so yeah the whole thing is just during
the you know because crunch time is
still a thing in game development right
right yeah unfortunately and it sucks
but it's it's kind of the reality
because Gamers expect so much out of a
game you know the features set the
graphics everything like that and so you
know my wife and I we bought a place at
the Carolina Shore and that was my
escape on the weekends during crunch
time and that's why Gears of War 3 ends
with Marcus and Anya sitting on the
beach and you know the idea of this this
pristine Beach location that's been kept
away from the proletariat workers and
and the the poor people you know was was
very much an idea I wanted to make sure
was in Gears uh three and so when you
know Anya turns to Marcus and says we
have it tomorrow I think that was one of
the best narrative decisions they made
was to give Marcus and Anya a son you
know and to continue the lineage because
Lord knows I don't freaking want one
did you